parce que Guadeloupe ça c'est la l'ultra
favorite de de l'élection
oui oui Guadeloupe c'est la plus jeune
elle a 18 ans Indira en Pio elle a 18
ans 18 ans plus jeune de la promo et
elle a ce visage vous voyez hein de
poupons assez c'est une beauté pure
de TV Mag exactement Miss Guadeloupe qui
dont la maman avait et dont la maman
avait participé à Miss Guadeloupe il y a
quelques années mais elle avait pas été
élu donc elle réalise à travers cette
élection le rêve de sa maman une
histoire
lundi matin et on fait le bilan
non vous m'arrêtez évidemment missile de
France ah j'ai vu une statistique sur
missile de France c'est la plus grande
de la promo un mètre 86
le mètre
elle ne fait pas partie des favoris et
d'autant que alors c'est déjà arrivé je
crois avec le Nord-Pas-de-Calais mais
c'est difficile pour une région de
gagner deux fois de suite c'est arrivé
avec Iris mittenaere et Camille serre je
vois vous y connaissez vos classiques
arrêtez-vous parce que Languedoc
alors comment s'appelle cette jeune
femme c'est Cameron Vallières
son prénom est un hommage de ses parents
à Cameron Diaz de Cameron Diaz ses
parents donc c'est un hommage et
Languedoc alors c'est un peu la Girl
Next Door celle qu'on voit pas arriver
mais qui pourrait
en premier lieu en tout cas mais bon
elle en veut en tout cas et elle se
débrouillait très bien au cours de
catwalk c'est les cours de catwalk c'est
les cours de défilé parce que on ne
défile pas sur un podium comme ça
alors d'accord donc il y a des fils très
bien euh le sling dog donc très bien et
elle en veut et elle parle très bien
aussi c'est important d'accord allez on
continue
Miss Limousin non vous vous avez fait
une petite vidéo je l'aime bien parce
qu'elle parle bien aussi elle est elle
est attachante mais
mode si on doit être objectif elle fait
pas partie des favorithmes
Martinique Midi-Pyrénées vous m'arrêtez
ça
non pas de calais parce qu'elle fait
partie des favorites c'est Agathe Cauet
elle fait pas partie de la famille de
Sébastien Cauet hein je devant votre
question
et Miss Nord-Pas-de-Calais alors elle a
une histoire qui peut toucher les
téléspectateurs parce qu'elle est elle a
été atteinte d'une tumeur alors qu'elle
avait seulement 17 d'accord elle a quel
âge elle a 23 ans je crois
le delta dash 18 ans pour la plus jeune
il y a plus de limite maintenant plus
limite d'âge donc la plus vieille
désormais à 26 ans alors qu'avant il y
avait la limite était à 24 d'accord
donc vous m'avez dit Agathe Cauet Agathe
Cauet 23 ans je crois mais je ne suis
pas sûr je m'avance peut-être et Agathe
Cauet qui a une tumeur donc alors
qu'elle était mineure et un kyste à
l'ovaire c'est bien qu'on lui a retiré
l'ovaire et elle porte un tatouage
représentant cette over perdue oui avec
avec Languedoc d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de
le préciser tout à l'heure Languedoc et
Nord-Pas-de-Calais sont les deux
candidats de tatoués de la promo
je je pense hein je connais pas cette
jeune femme voilà on verra
Normandie a gagné le test de culture
générale ce qui quasiment lui permet de
d'attendre
on est quasi sûr c'est arrivé qu'une
fois ou deux que la fille en question ne
soit pas parmi les 15 mais a priori
grâce à son à sa bonne note 17 et demi
sur 20 alors j'ai vu aussi dans votre
article que Diane avait participé au
concours de la santé le test parce que
elle veut pas nous dire sa note de
l'année dernière mais on suppose que
elle avait pas eu une très bonne note
tout juste la moyenne c'est pas vrai et
alors là j'ai vu qu'elle a une bonne
note 19 sur 20 donc elle a été meilleure
que les candidates et elle a même rendu
avant tout le monde au bout de 15
minutes
Calédonie donc la seule rousse hein
Pays de la Loire est-ce qu'on a fait le
tour des favoris je m'arrête sur
picardie parce que Picardie fait partie
des favorites
également du Bérénice Legendre elle a 26
ans c'est l'une des doyennes de la promo
26 et elle pareil son histoire et peut
toucher puisqu'elle a perdu son frère il
y a en mars dernier dans un accident de
voiture donc il se peut que pendant son
discours si elle attend les 15 bien sûr
qu'elle parle de son frère et que ça
touche les téléspectateurs
Picardie donc et on s'approche
tranquillement de la fin alors qu'on
touche à rendre pardon non ah vous me
faites un nom catégorique
non mais
pas vraiment parce que pour tout vous
dire dans la rédaction les gens sont
assez convaincus par Miss Provence c'est
vrai
je suis pas d'accord avec eux
Ronald
c'est la dernière favorite s'il devait y
en avoir une pareil ça c'est celle qu'on
ne voit pas arriver c'est comme
languedocaine parce que elle donc elle
elle a un truc c'est-à-dire que elle
veut défiler les cheveux bouclés elle a
les cheveux boucles vous le voyez et
alors en quoi c'est alors c'est
peut-être bête à dire mais souvent les
les filles bouclées ne se font pas une
place de choix lors de l'élection et
c'est toutes les cheveux et elle se lise
toutes les cheveux Amandine petit avait
fait ça il y a deux ans et
Chiara fontaine ce sont non veut
absolument garder ses cheveux bouclés
elle dit que c'est sa force et je crois
que ça peut être sa force elle a un très
joli sourire ce qui compte beaucoup
aussi pour pour le top 5 il faut sourire
longuement ça fait mal
d'accord donc Miss Roussillon s'appelle
attention à Miss Roussillon quand même
euh
Saint-Martin Saint-Barth la 30 ans
bon on a fait le tour